secretive ill-mannered yet brave and
loyal to a fault
the dwarves of middle-earth are some of
the most curious creatures
in all of tolkien's works and these sons
of durian
play a unique and truly special role in
the history of the lord of the rings
universe
the dwarves have an origin unlike any
other in middle earth
long ago the races of elves and men were
given life
by iluvatar the creator of middle earth
and they're known far and wide as his
children
the dwarves however come from somewhere
else
they're crafted by owlet one of the
valar
the pantheon of angelic guardians who
first helped a
bring the universe into existence known
to his dwarven subcreations as
mahal aole fashions the dwarves in the
very early days of middle earth's
existence
having grown impatient at the slow
awakening of the children
of eluvitar shaped deep under a mountain
in middle earth
the first batch of owlette's creations
were known
as the seven fathers of the dwarves
eventually the all-knowing eluvitar
calls owlet
out on his impatience he points out that
while
owlet may be a master craftsman he lacks
the power to give each dwarf their own
will
seeing that his creations are little
more than empty husks
owlette repents and offers to destroy
them
but iluvatar decides to spare his
repentant servants handiwork
giving the dwarves independent will and
adopting them into his family of
children
each of the seven fathers is then put to
sleep
and spread across middle earth where
they remain in silent slumber
until the elves finally begin to awake
the first dwarf to stir from his slumber
is durin
the father of the dwarven clan known as
the longbeards
after waking up durian wanders around
middle earth
before settling down in the area that
eventually becomes khazad doom
or moria as the elves later call it
four of the other dwarven fathers wake
up far to the east
and they aren't talked about much in
tolkien's work
however the last pair of dwarven fathers
appear in the blue mountains to the west
of kazadum
and they found the famous cities of
bellagost
and nograd these two cities play an
important part in the first stage of
middle-earth history
as the inhabitants befriend the elven
exiles who live in the western region
known
as balariand and join them in their war
against the dark lord morgoth
they also help the elves carve out their
vast underground palaces
craft their gems and weapons and even
aid them in battle
unfortunately this peaceful time is
short-lived
after a great elven king refuses to pay
up for their work
the dwarves kill him setting off a
bitter feud that sparks several
retaliatory conflicts
and feeds into a less than savory
reputation for the dwarves
at the end of the first age morgoth is
defeated
valerian is sunk under the sea and the
surviving dwarves in the blue mountains
travel east to join their relatives in
the misty mountains
during the second age of middle-earth
many of the survivors from bellagost and
nograd
joined the thriving kingdom of khazad
doom where their knowledge and
experience launched the dwarven realm
into further glory at this point the
western gates of khazad doom
open right up into the elvish kingdom of
origin
the region the fellowship of the ring
later travels through on their way to
mordor
at first the second age sees a healing
of the relationship between the elves
and the dwarves
at one point they even allow galadriel
to journey through kazadum
so that she can visit lothlorien for the
first time
later war breaks out between the elves
and morgoth's greatest lieutenant
sauron and in response the dwarves pour
out of kazadum to aid their allies
but their help comes too late and the
dwarves are forced to retreat back into
their mountain kingdom
after that the dwarves mostly stay out
of the war
it's not until the final showdown with
sauron
during the war of the last alliance that
the dwarves of kaza doom
come out to support the free peoples of
middle earth
but the battles of the later second age
weren't the dwarves first encounter with
sauron
earlier in that era sauron had attempted
to bring
durin's folk under his influence by
offering rings of power
to the seven great dwarf kings when
sauron forges his master ring however
he's unable to control the dwarven kings
instead
he finds that the tough hardiness of the
dwarves makes him more or less
impervious to his direct control
but that doesn't mean the dwarven rings
are harmless
although they don't fall under sauron's
spell
the dwarf rings kindle an overpowering
greed for
gold in the hearts of their owners a
greed that later brings great ruin to no
small number of dwarven lords these
rings also amplify their skills
and desires and each one is supposed to
have been the foundation of a great
dwarven horde of wealth
eventually four of the dwarven rings are
destroyed by dragon fire
while the other three are recovered by
sauron leaving the dwarves to manage
their great wealth
without the powers of their magical
rings
after the first defeat of sauron the
third age begins fairly quietly
the dwarves go on busily mining in their
underground kingdoms
and kaza doom in particular continues to
thrive
roughly thirteen hundred years into the
age
orcs begin to repopulate and harass the
dwarves in maurya
but they're mostly held at bay by the
warriors of kaza doom
then in the year 1980 of the third age
something terrible happens the dwarves
of khazad doom
wake up belrog you know what they awoke
in the darkness of
khazar doom
shadow and flame
this ancient servant of morgoth kills
king doran vi
and forces the longbeards to flee their
ancient home
and scatter across the world some of
them find their way to the lonely
mountain
in irebor where they establish a new
kingdom under the mountain
others meanwhile head north and settle
in the grey mountains
although these particular refugees
managed to rebuild their strength over
the next few centuries
their relocation to the north of
middle-earth puts them in close
proximity to the withered heath
a land populated by dragons
conflict soon erupts between the dwarves
and their new fiery neighbors
and most of the survivors are forced to
relocate all over again
this time joining their kin under the
lonely mountain
unfortunately the dragons aren't done
with the dwarves just yet
one drake in particular hears of the
great riches of the lonely mountain
and decides to pay a visit to the
dwarves of erebor
when smaug attacks the lonely mountain
it spells
doom for the longbeards already driven
out of moria by durhan's bane
the few surviving dwarves once again
find themselves on the run
many head further east to the iron hills
another group of dwarves under the king
throar
head south where they adopt a wandering
homeless lifestyle
after that the dwarf king thrower
becomes tired of his people's constant
defeats
and lonely wanderings and starts to go a
little bit
out of his mind he decides to head back
to moria to scout out the land
whereupon he's quickly killed and
mutilated by the orcs that have taken up
residence
in the dwarves absence this act of
regicide sparks the war of the dwarves
and orcs
over the next three years dwarves from
all of the seven households gathered
together
to attack the orcs of the misty
mountains the war culminates with an
epic battle
in front of the gates of moria where
according to the books
they successfully killed the orc leader
azog
after their victory the dwarves refused
to repopulate moria
knowing that there's a balrog on the
loose and they scattered back to their
homes
leaving the longbeard still without a
home
roughly 150 years after the battle
outside
moria thorin oakenshield meets gandalf
the grey
in the innet bree they recruit a dozen
dwarves in a certain timid hobbit
and set out on a quest to reclaim their
treasure from smaug
nope after the dragon is defeated and
the kingdom under the mountain is
restored
the dwarves find a new lease on life
with a new hoard of gold and jewels in
hand
they set up shop as one of the dominant
forces in northern middle earth
just in time for the war of the ring
while the dwarves aren't shown much
throughout the lord of the rings
they do play an important side role by
helping to keep the forces of evil at
bay in the north
in fact in the appendix for the return
of the king
gandalf explains that dane the dwarven
king at the time
is killed fighting easterlings at the
gates of irobor
nevertheless the dwarves and their
allies successfully keep the northern
regions of middle-earth safe
while the events in the main narrative
unfold
after the war of the ring wraps up gimli
returns to the lonely mountain
and brings a group of his people back to
rohan or more specifically
to helm's deep there the dwarves
establish
a new home in the glittering caves a
place that gimli himself dubbed
one of the marvels of the northern world
in the two towers
gimli now the lord of the glittering
caves
also helps to repair the broken gates of
menace tirith
around this time it is also said that
king during the seventh
the last king to be named after the
founder of the longbeards
finally reclaims casadoom and restores
it to its former glory
eventually the dwarves begin to diminish
in importance
and their race slowly dwindles until it
comes to an end
at an undisclosed point in time perhaps
the most fitting ending to the dwarven
history is the touching story that gimli
friend to elves an avid devotee to
galadriel
is eventually given permission to board
one of the last
ships to the undying lands he sails west
with his friend legolas
to enjoy an earthly retirement in the
blessed realm beyond the sea
and he's reportedly the only dwarf to
ever be given such an honor so
you know the history of the dwarves and
how they first came to be
but here's the question just what are
dwarves in tolkien's mythology
it's clear enough from their origins
that the dwarves are unique
among the many races of middle earth but
they have plenty of other facets that
make them distinct from elves
men or hobbits too
take their basic physicality for example
dwarves are short
but not quite as short as hobbits who
are typically between two
and four feet tall in comparison dwarves
usually come in
at around four to four and a half feet
tall they're also tremendously strong
stout and stocky while hobbits are known
for their clean-shaven faces
dwarves are specifically marked by their
remarkably long beards
which they wear with great pride when
aole first created the dwarves
he designed them to be tough in order to
endure the perils of middle earth
they're also famously stubborn and
always remain
incredibly loyal to their friends and
equally bitter to their enemies
while there's no hard and fast number
regarding their lifespan
they definitely outlive men and often
live to be hundreds of years old
with dwollen in particular living to the
ripe old age of 340.
culturally the dwarves share many things
with the other free peoples of middle
earth
although they tend to put their own
unique spin on each one
their music for instance is highly
developed and in the hobbit
all of thorin's companions show off
their musical skills on a number of
different instruments
but unlike the music of the elves most
of their songs aren't light and ethereal
they're slow methodical and moody
the dwarven language is also unique the
silmarillion states that aolei
invented a language for them and began
to teach it to them
right at their inception their language
is said to be cumbrious and unlovely
and is kept very secret indeed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]